if you look back to the very first
moment that you wrote code in this
lesson you'll notice that you've been
following a very simple pattern of code
test and refine you'll write some code
test and see how it looks against the
design mock-up that you received and
then make any refinements or
modifications to the code so that it
looks closer to the design and you'll
repeat this process of testing and
modifying until it looks like the design
you were given but how do you know where
to start testing and then how do you
also know what to refine so that it
looks closer to the design first you
need to get the structure of the page
right you should be able to do that from
the design by visually box off' eyeing
it then move on to work on the tags if
something needs to be a heading make it
so then think about the size of the
boxes how big should they be and then
how to position them where you want on
the screen once the general layout is
complete the time has come for smaller
details and these you can polish until
the page looks exactly like the design
image you were given
so to summarize first make sure to
divide and conquer look for places that
are distinct everything on the web is a
box so look for the natural boxes then
look for repeated styles and semantic
elements h2 should be the second biggest
headings on the page and things like
that think about how you can relate this
to HTML elements then write your HTML
then apply your styles go from your
biggest site-wide elements to your
smallest like widgets then fix the small
things look at your site and other
browsers resize your window and just
keep repeating steps 3 & 4 until you're
happy and your website looks like the
design MOC